- Attention of human beings is the asset.
(electronic music)
You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
What's up everybody?
This is an epic two hour
Q&A session from Phoenix
where we just completely
brought down the house.
This is the long form content
that you've been begging for.
Enjoy, enjoy, enjoy, happy holidays.
- [Man] Do you often see people
get caught up in thinking
that whatever their thing is has to be
a hundred million dollar endeavor
versus saying like for me and
farming in southwest Missouri
in rural area.
I mean if I had grew
something to a couple several,
just a few million dollars a year.
I mean that's wildly successful.
Do you think a lot of
people focus too much on...
- Yes.
It's my favorite thing to talk about,
like if you make, what's
wrong with 137 thousand a year
if you're happy and you
enjoy the fuck out of it
and that's real money to you, yes I do.
But that doesn't mean anything to you,
meaning 90% of the marketing
establishing world.
The mad, I don't know how
many of you watch Mad Men,
or know what an advertising
agency in New York City is.
90% of that world thinks I'm full of shit.
- [Man] Why?
- Because they're holding on
to the past and I'm dangerous.
Because they make money selling
newspaper ads and billboards
and television commercials.
- [Man] Do they think your full of shit
or just hope you're full of shit?
- They think I'm full
of because 90% of them
that work in those companies
believe in their religion.
- [Man] I've pissed so much money away.
- Do you understand?
They don't know.
They went to school.
They paid, they don't,
it's subconscious bias.
It's subconscious bias.
They went to a good university,
they work at Ogilvie or
McCann or Wieden Kennedy
or Crispin Porter, like they don't know.
They believe in their truth.
They think a 30-second commercial
is worth spending millions of dollars on,
That's what they believe they believe.
They believe that I'm
a snake oil salesman.
Yet they go home and watch Netflix
and stay on Instagram all day.
(laughing)
I mean it, I mean it.
They say things like luxury
doesn't work that way Gary.
Right, like Vogue, we
need a Vogue full-page ad.
Not in my business, not in
my business, not my demo.
Yeah.
- [Man] I'm going to hopefully
ask questions for everyone
because I'm hoping--
- Yeah, listen everybody gets, ask your,
the reason we have time
is ask your question.
Nuances will filter.
- [Man] So my question
is going to a place where
when you do take on debt--
- Yep.
- [Man] I don't take on a lot of debt
just because I'm at a place
where I don't need to--
- And is your debt in the form
of a loan or credit line or?
- [Man] It depends.
It depends if we're buying
a buying a bunch of houses.
It also depends on you know,
certain structures, I mean it
just depends on what it is.
Right, so quick loans versus credit cards
versus personal loans to the company.
- Okay.
- [Man] Do you ever get,
does that ever weigh on you?
- It's the scariest thing on earth.
This is why so many
people in your business
go out of business.
You're the ultimate cliche.
You came in when the market was shit,
you had less to lose, crushed it,
now you get high on your
supply, you get over leveraged.
Guys, it happens in one day.
Tomorrow you wake up, it just happens.
You do know that, I mean
like, how old are you?
- [Man] 30.
- You don't know.
(laughing)
How old are you?
- [Man] 29.
- Definitely not.
But the rest of everybody else here,
'cause you haven't lived it yet.
You didn't live it.
- [Man] I've heard that before.
- You didn't live it.
You didn't live just waking up
and the April stock market
crash of 2001 and it's over.
You didn't live 2008, Bear Stearns.
You heard about it, you
might have heard something,
your daddy might have been upset.
You heard something,
you didn't give a fuck.
You didn't live it.
You didn't live, I woke up
in the morning that day,
I was in France buying
wine and Brandon calls me,
because it's early, it's
six hours ahead there,
it happened in the morning.
Bear Stearns, da, da, da.
Brennan calls me goes hey.
I was like hey.
He's like we've had like
$400,000 in pre-order wine
canceled this morning.
I'm like okay.
Right?
Like literally I remember where I was.
I started buying less wine than I did
the first two days of the trip.
First two days our trip, I'm
a big shot like. (slurps)
I'll take a hundred cases of that.
I'll take 50 cases of that.
Literally an hour, I'm like
yeah, this is not that great.
(laughing)
Thanks for your time.
So yeah bro, I would high
and listen, you're no dummy.
Debt is awfully scary if
your business doesn't do well
when the economy collapses.
If yours does, look, I
think Vaynermedia explodes.
I do because I think when
Aquafina wakes up and realizes
and it happens in a day.
Remember, it takes 30
to 60 days for it all
to get figured out but it happens in a day
and when they get into a
board meeting on March 9th
and they're like okay,
we had 83 million in marketing this year.
Now that's been cut to nine million.
What are we doing with that money?
I have a funny feeling
that Gary V character
might know what to do with it
way better than Madison Avenue
student who's critiquing me,
so I think we're gonna explode.
But I think your business won't.
- [Man] Well, it depends.
- Correct, correct.
- Real Estate, because I can shift
from flipping to holding--
- You could do a ton of stuff,
but it depends on how
the debt is compounding.
- [Man] Well I'm bringing that up,
because right now I'm debt free.
- I get it and you have
these opportunities.
- [Man] There's a lot of opportunities
that are on the shift--
- Look, if we were
partners I'd be like bro,
honestly here's my plan.
It's been so good for so long,
let's actually be humble as fuck.
Let's just, let's just
actually hoard cash.
You have to understand.
A million dollars in your bank
account today in the world
versus what happens when the world melts,
that millions worth like four.
Got it?
It's an interesting perspective, right?
- [Man] I like to save in
cash, I love cash, right?
I love to every morning be like--
- It matters bro and honestly
at some point you got to say
it's no different than like I don't know
what the blackjack fucking rules are,
but I know that you keep
going and then at some point
if it's like 11 hands or six
or I don't know the fucking rules,
but at some point you're
like fuck, I got...
like the math is just
not on your side anymore.
We are so deep in this world
of like inflated bullshit.
- [Man] So less leverage, more cash?
- I think so.
Mainly because I think
you're gonna pick up shit
for a fucking penny on the dollar
and so like it'll suck right now.
It sucks for me.
I'm sitting around just watching,
sitting on cash being like
I'm an idiot, like right?
But I won't be at some point.
It's gonna happen.
It's no different in a 50 year
window, I don't give a shit.
It takes another four years.
Especially and this is how I hedged it,
because I'm building a
machine that capitalizes
on the other side.
So I would actually tell
you try to think about that
or build your personal brand
and start talking about the truth of
I came in when shit was terrible.
It's been really good.
I don't know when the other shit happens,
but let's interview people
that were the me in 2007
who thought they were big shots,
who are now social media experts
or cryptocurrency experts
or cannabis experts 'cause
they got blown the fuck out
by real estate, 'cause in
2008 they were feeling great.
They went the other way
than what I'm telling you
and over leveraged themselves.
Did their biggest project ever
and then Bear Stearns
put them out of business.
- [Woman] Even though our
product is an experience.
You pick up like the lock
that I built for your mom.
- Yep.
- [Woman] You pick up those little charms
and create a story.
It can be done online,
but where I'm really struggling right now
is should we train our team,
retrain these 40,000 women.
Do I train them to do
your business your way
and show three ways to be successful?
Do I say hey, all this is old school,
you've got to stop doing that
and how quickly do I try to shift them
in to all social media or online selling?
- If I was your partner I would say
number one way more than
number two with a kicker.
Let them do it their way.
I'm a huge fan of self-awareness.
I'm a huge fan of not putting,
I'm a huge fan of putting
people in a position to succeed.
Some people are just fabulous
when they invite the
neighborhood to their living room
and other people want to lay on their bed
with grainy light and
just be like buy my shit
and people buy that that way.
So I'm big on letting, I'm
big on their way, comma,
it's my actions over my words.
I'm big on do it your way right.
Do it the best way that you
communicate on social platforms.
P.S. LinkedIn works better with writing.
So to me it's your way, comma,
our corporate point of view
of where the fertile ground is
is the following and before
you say no try to say yes.
You don't like to do Facebook,
but you're a 40,000 a month kind of gal,
then fucking hire somebody.
- [Woman] What would you recommend?
If you were my business partner
and you knew where we were
and we had wild success,
we had a huge crash
and now we have leveled out,
but we're building again.
What would you do?
How would you sell our jewelry
knowing we have a 40,000 person base?
- You mean how would you sell
the people that are selling it
to be more progressive or--
- [Woman] How would you encourage
our people to sell in 2019?
- What would be the advice
I would give him to sell?
Versus then what should
we do to inspire him
to actually do my advice?
- [Woman] That's exactly right.
- I would tell him to sell
him sell on Instagram stories
and on YouTube and podcast.
I would tell them everything
I put out every day.
The Internet's the real world,
the real world's the fake world.
That's my fucking answer.
And the quicker people
start understanding that,
the quicker their behavior will change.
I understand how ideologically fun it is
to think of an old time
when you read your fucking
newspaper with a coffee
and the world was nice and slow.
Mazel Tov!
That doesn't exist anymore.
There used to be a time when we used to
shoot a fucking elephant and eat it raw.
Like it's over.
I'm sorry it's not fucking 1949 anymore.
- [Woman] So you would encourage...
so if he were one of my designers,
affiliates, distributors,
whatever you want to call it,
you would encourage him go
social from the business model,
your business, your way.
If this is what you love, but hey,
before you say you're only
going to do it this way,
try this and from a corporate
perspective, we train--
- From a corporate perspective
I would quadruple down
on in-person events and
content to inspire our team.
- [Woman] In-person events
and content to inspire--
- The sellers.
You know, it's like this.
Do this, do this, do this,
versus hey come here let
me show you how to do this.
Those are two very different things.
It's very cute for you
to make a 40 second video
and me to say go do it.
It's different than actually like okay
and on Monday we're gonna train you
how to post an Instagram story
and on Tuesday we're
gonna have Becky Thompson,
mama bear on Instagram showing how she did
and on Wednesday we're gonna do this.
And don't forget this
Saturday in Atlanta, Dallas,
and El Paso we're at the Holiday Inn
doing fucking physical workshops.
- [Woman] And that's the value?
- Correct.
- [Woman] Showing someone
else doing it is--
- A 100%.
Outside of your world,
because you don't want to
put pressure on other
sellers who think that
you're forcing them to give up
their competitive advantage,
which will dilute their advantage.
- [Man] Can I ask a question?
- Yeah.
- [Man] You have relationships
with these sellers,
can you incentivize,
platform incentivize them?
Like encourage them through
some sort of contest
or something for like the most things
sold through Instagram stories.
- You could, but what you're doing then is
you're creating bad behavior.
One of the things that
people don't understand
about the psychology of people
is short-term incentives
are short-term incentives.
The quality of your customer matters,
the quality of your employee matters,
the reason I don't have a
one-size-fits-all for my employees
is DRock's not motivated by title.
But I have 137 people that are.
- [Woman] But how do
you get the 137 people,
it would also be really
hard for us to track.
That is what you suggested,
but how do you get the 137 people
that don't want to be
the old marketing agency
that can think new and fresh
because the majority of people--
- Actions by actions.
By putting out the content.
I try to convince no one.
I just end up being historically correct.
- [Woman] But I mean hiring.
So hiring whoever you hire
on your team internally,
how do you not get the old school,
how do you find the people
without the old school--
- I got it, I do, ready?
- [Woman] When you say all
video people look at you like
you got a print an ad
in Vogue, like you said.
But it's not reality.
- By firing.
The answer to your question is
a very interesting question.
I don't.
I didn't know what the
fuck DRock was gonna do.
I was just prepared to
fire him after 90 days
if he wasn't good.
The answer to hiring is actually firing.
Do you know how the Seattle
Seahawks won their Super Bowl?
They kept cutting the 50th
to 53rd guy on the team
consistently and kept picking up new guys
until 50 to 53 can also contribute.
It was very smart.
And that's how I think about it.
It's what Jack Welsh did.
He made it very 10/80/10,
but there's a lot of right to that.
- [Woman] Find the innovator thinkers
and if they're not you let them go.
- And you do a much better job up front
to make sure that people
know they could get fired.
Like my big thing is kindness and empathy
and like a good culture,
so when I'm hiring somebody very senior
and I'm involved in the
process I'm like look,
you're not gonna believe me.
You kind of think I actually
care about the money.
You're gonna think that
you're just gonna come
and contribute money like you always have
and I'm gonna look the other way
if you're mean in a meeting.
I'm not.
So let me save you a ton of
time, go work somewhere else,
this is my religion.
You can do that about being
a progressive marketer.
Got it?
So you put pressure up
front and then you deliver.
- [Woman] Pressure and expectations.
- You bark up front and you bite.
Got it?
- [Man] To me it's very misunderstood,
because from time of five to 18
we're told to go down
this distribution model
and it's shoved down our throats
and so for the entrepreneurs of the world,
it's like okay, you were that voice
that like finally stood
up and said enough.
And so dude I am so forever grateful.
I mean what you've done...
I went from making 25 hundred
bucks a month three years ago
to making over a million dollars a year.
I made 25,000 and I took
it on the thing that
and the old network
markers hate to hear this,
I work for them.
And I'm building a legacy around that,
that I'm like dude I
bought all of your shit
'cause it works.
- The next step for you is,
the problem with network marketing
and I have a lot of empathy
for that five to 18 year old thing.
Here's the truth of it.
I mean otherwise I would do it full-time.
The math doesn't work when
you start adding layers.
It just doesn't and it's
not how humans work.
Like to me I'm gonna
pitch you the 3.0 for you.
Where it gets really crazy is if you...
to me I love a one-to-one relationship
that makes a ton of sense,
but when you start playing
with the math of what happens
when he goes and sells
there and what happens to me
and things of that nature,
you start getting into real,
you want to talk about this?
You start getting into really...
you get into different incentives.
People are in the business
of selling people people.
And as you know, you can't
control that at some point.
The end.
The end, I don't know what else to say...
- [Man] Well no, this time though,
I didn't go buy stupid shit.
- I get it.
That I understand.
That's different, but--
- Just like you.
- I get it.
- Putting it all the way,
because when the hits the
fan 'cause it's going to,
my background is I'm former stockbroker.
I have a good understanding of the markets
and so on so forth and it's coming.
The punch in the face,
it's gonna be like the 92,
it's gonna happen so quick.
I don't know if it's
Black Swan or whatever.
We can't control, but I'm gonna
be ready for it this time.
- Yep.
- [Man] So you wrote a point, I'm sorry.
- Go ahead, go ahead.
Go ahead.
Cool, no worries.
We'll get to everybody, go ahead brother.
- [Man] I have sort of two questions
related to something you were saying--
- Go ahead.
- [Woman] But thank you
for that, next question.
- [Man] Well no, I was just wondering
'cause it's kind of what I do too but--
- Just to put a bow on that,
too many people spend time
on strategies and executions
and systems that create
short-term behavior
that looks good and then
becomes bad long-term behavior.
It's why Zynga went out
of business in theory.
It was great to acquire
customers on Facebook
at such a low cost,
but if you weren't creating
something that was keeping them
so when you incentivize behavior
that isn't naturally gonna
be what the person's doing it
and they're doing it for that
thing, it becomes the lottery.
It's communism's theory.
It's like you to me you
bet on human truths.
Here's a human truth.
People are incentivized
by different things
even as an individual as
they go through their lives.
Whatever system you can create to continue
understanding that and feeding that.
When I really talk about
being there for my employees
like that is just basically my life.
I just feel like a much more Deion Sanders
than I'm Jerry Rice.
I am they're reacting to everything.
I'm a counter-puncher.
That's why Floyd Mayweather
was so good in boxing.
It didn't excite everybody.
It's not you fucking...
it wasn't Mike Tyson.
It's defense, it's perfect defense.
It's reactionary so to me
if Karen just loves
throwing house parties,
I don't want to put guilt on
her for not being on Instagram,
but I don't want to not tell
her to think about Instagram
and make her say Karen,
being live on Instagram,
could feel like hosting a party
especially as we go into
eight faces in a screen.
Like don't say no.
Bet on your strengths, but don't say no.
Like Vayner at its best
and what our team is,
for sure, is we're yes culture.
Everything's just yes.
And that's how I hire.
I don't take any pride in
like thinking I hire great.
I don't hire great.
I hire on complete and utter intuition,
which sometimes works out remarkable
and plenty times does not.
I'm just capable of firing.
Because I don't care about the judgment
of making the wrong call, which
bugs the shit out of people.
It's a killer for people.
They hire somebody, they talk a big game
to their team that's been with them.
They're like Rick's gonna
fucking kill it for us,
then Rick's a idiot who
came to just like hang on
and then my three homies
like you're fucking wrong,
but I'm fuck I don't wanna,
I'm gonna fix Rick
because I can't be wrong
in front of the homies.
Ego.
- [Man] Kills.
Kills so much.
- It's insecurity with makeup brother.
- [Man] But how did you get through
with the sensitivity of lost time.
If you got somebody--
- I made the bet, bro.
- [Man] I know, I get it.
- The end.
The lost time is about to be
compounded if I don't cut bait.
Right?
This is why people lose money.
- [Man] How or why would you
ever either give away equity
for a new company project or something,
versus taking on debt,
to go to your question,
to grow if you want to grow,
if you need that money
in a salary somehow---
- Taking on debt is
betting on yourself more
than giving away equity.
It's a safer bet to give away equity.
- [Man] Yeah and then with that,
how would you hire people
to help you be you,
because for example--
- That's super easy.
It depends on how truthful
you're willing to be with yourself.
So for hiring people to
allow you to be you to be you
starts with how well do you know you?
For you to be you, you need to recognize
what either you like the most
or what you're the best at.
And the best is if you can
really hit the delta of the two.
Like if you're great at
sales and you love it,
you love the high of selling.
A lot of sales people become CEOs,
because their companies
start to become a company.
What they don't realize is
they hate being an operator
and an executive, they just
love being a salesperson,
but the humility to hire a CEO
to be your boss of the company you started
as a sales person seems
fucking outrageous.
- [Man] Not to cut you off-
- You're not cutting me off.
- So I am right in that point now.
I'm trying to understand.
I've tried to be self-aware so much
that one of my questions is like
are you ever your own worst enemy
as you're trying to be self-aware
thinking did I like second guess myself.
- Something I've been
talking about a lot lately
is the inability to judge myself.
So the answer is no.
That's where I'm really strong.
I just don't dwell, I don't judge.
I've come to realize it
has so much to do with
not caring about other people's opinions,
so I don't second-guess myself.
There's just no time.
- [Man] Is that a process
or was that from the get go?
- That was pretty in there,
that was pretty in there,
but that then reinforced through watching
how it played out for me
for 20 years versus my dad
versus my brother versus lots
of businesses I'm involved,
all the interaction.
It's no different than the lost time.
I do not calibrate, I cut bait emotionally
and like mentally so quickly,
'cause it's not valuable.
Like you made the decision.
- [Man] But I get slowed down in operating
and executing on that level,
because in the process
everything else has to go.
Like I value the setup of the camera.
So I'm trying to do that simultaneously
to actually getting the
person to fit in the role.
I think the biggest thing maybe DRock....
No, no this is perfect.
I think DRock, I just kind
of caught his reaction.
DRock talk to me about
perfection or the idea of it.
I think like what his and I reaction was
when you were talking like first of all,
this is something I don't
say as often as I used to
just 'cause it takes a lot of explanation,
but like 99% of things that
are going through your head
right now about your
business don't matter.
I really believe that.
That's a brain fuck.
(laughing)
- [DRock] Gary's never told me one time
how to put the camera and where to put it.
He doesn't watch 90% of
the videos that I put out.
I mean, the 10% is Instagram.
- [Man] But even though
he said that the content
really matters to him, he
trusts you enough and then--
- Nope, I trust the market.
- [Man] How the market reacts--
- I value the volume over the debate.
It's an output game.
- [Man] Gotcha.
- Back to sports, you
can watch film all week.
I've learned so much about football,
because of the agency we
have, me and my brother.
You can watch film all week.
If you're not able to execute
on the field on Sunday
and some other guys been
going to the club all week
and he can play on the field on Sunday.
Results speak.
- [DRock] If he had to watch
every video that we made,
we not put any content or video on YouTube
and it's kept me busy.
- It's why articles don't go out.
It's why articles don't go out
I'm the bottleneck I have to
hear the new writer write it,
because it's got to be me
and I have to, you know?
Video is me!
This is fucking me.
I'm on the record.
And that's back to like why
I was okay with you filming,
like I'm on the record.
I made that decision in 2009.
Everything I do.
When there is no camera is on the record,
especially now that I'm actually known.
Like now I actually know that to be true.
There is no me doing anything
without somebody watching.
- [Man] Can I maybe throw
two cents just to clarify?
- Hell yeah.
- [Man] Were you talking
about the hiring/firing
of these salespeople and that
you're handling that role...
- [Man] In the delta time between--
- [Man] You actually
doing what you need to do.
- Go ahead.
Honestly it's bigger
than that in my opinion.
I just think you're debating
shit that doesn't matter.
You're auditing yourself
for no fucking reason
out of a personality trait
and just being in the
beginning of the process.
My big thing is just fucking do.
Do you know many people
spend three years doing,
because they don't know
anything about anything,
they get successful and
then they start changing
everything that got them there?
Almost everyone.
I go the other way.
I try to get dumber.
Here's the problem.
Family businesses are binary.
There's only one boss.
And what's so powerful
about this conversation
was really funny the delta of
looking you, your twenty what?
- [Man] 29.
- So you know one of the
things as you two probably know
if you follow my content, being younger,
like I talk so much about
patience and how long life is
and as he's talking,
just watching your face was a lot of fun.
He's talking about my, you're
saying like kudos to you,
meanwhile there's a
older generation in him
in the fucking game.
(laughing)
- [Woman] I was like whoa, what.
- Right and I'm like trying
to get people to understand
71, 85, 79, like...
life is long boy.
Like yes you could die--
- [Man] Someone wants to
open another business.
- Of course he does.
So and this is where I
talk about like patience
and like you know like I mean...
there's so many dynamics,
but I will say this
for the four of us and
everybody was watching
and for the rest of us
like there's only one boss.
And where people get confused is
in the lack of clarity
of that of the pictures
we paint in our own mind.
There's only one boss and
she or he is that boss
and until they say they're
not and start acting on it,
everything will be murky.
And you have sons who are cool with it.
He said it was tough for him to watch it.
He was cool with it, he liked it.
His dad was his hero, he was content,
he was content with what
he had, others are not.
I wasn't.
So you want to talk about
bailing on an employee
after you gave him four months.
What about building a business
from three to 60 million
and walking away with zero?
- [Man] You walked away with nothing?
- Nothing.
Guys, Wine Library started
in a conference room
of another company.
If I had money I wouldn't have started it
in Buddy Media's conference room.
I was 34 years old and had nothing.
I never talked about
it because at the time
that this started all happening with me
I resented my dad about it.
It didn't feel right to me.
18 months ago two things
happened simultaneously,
which is why I've
started talking about it.
One, I was so in Silicon
Valley corporate like business
that I lost the reminder of
what a family business is,
which is it's the old man
or old woman's business
until they die and then you get it.
And I forgot.
All of a sudden in a (snaps)
whenever I remembered I
was like wait a minute,
it's not my dad's fault.
This is just that game.
It's the old school game.
That's the immigrant coming
to a new country game.
You build the shit, you
die, the kid takes it.
There's no thoughts of
capital fucking gains
and income tax and inheritance,
they don't even know that shit.
These are people that
write on paper and cash
and who give a fuck, right?
So I got away from that and listen,
I also was an extreme example.
I really built a huge business as a kid,
gave up my entire childhood.
My hyperbole is as real as fuck.
You wake up and you're 32
and you had no childhood.
I had no childhood
,like let's get it very,
very, very real to this room.
From 14 to 34 I worked.
Every minute.
1953 shit.
I didn't go to parties.
I didn't go on vacation.
So you wake up and now you're walking,
it doesn't feel great.
Number two, I was
starting to impact people
and people were using it as an excuse
of why not to listen to me
and I had to create clarity
because I didn't want no people,
I didn't want kids to
follow losers instead of me,
because they made the
excuse of not wanting to
hear the hard work part by
saying well his dad gave him.
So I was like I gotta create,
I'm getting razzed for something
I'm the extreme reverse of.
I'm, you know?
I'm the reverse of entitled.
But real quick, to go
back to your business.
The thing I'm probably most
excited about is real life.
As the world becomes Internet
and real life becomes fake,
it's the same thesis I have on Facebook.
As everyone's about to run
away, I'm about to go back in.
I love real world.
I'm obsessed with it.
There's a reason concerts are up.
The movie theater is doing tremendous.
We're so deep in our
shit that we do yearn.
We also do things in real
life now for the content.
People literally hike
and go to Disney World
for the picture.
There are fucked-up families
where the mom and dad
hate each other that go to Disney
to take a picture in
from the Magic Kingdom
to post on Facebook to trick
people that the family is okay.
- [Woman] That's what's repelling
people from social media.
- Of course it is, but guess
what people are fucking stupid.
Let me explain why.
Fucking Facebook's not
making you fake, you're fake.
- [Woman] It's true.
- Mother fucker.
(laughing)
Like you can shut down your
Instagram and Facebook,
you're gonna be fake at the coffee shop.
You're gonna be fake at the PTA meeting.
- [Woman] People are
planning their whole day
around the picture they are gonna get.
- People are fake.
People are fake,
because they care about
other people's opinions.
Especially people they
don't even care about.
It's the most broken, it's
a lack of self esteem.
So anyway I'm obsessed with real life shit
and as a matter of fact I
don't know your business
well enough, and back
to your business too.
One thing I'm obsessed with is extremes.
If I started an events business,
if I was like in the
blowup castle business
to rent to like bar
mitzvahs and birthdays,
what I would do tomorrow
is go to fucking China
and make the most extreme
castle of all time.
Like a 900 foot castle.
Because what's happening
in our society right now
is it's minimalism and it's extremism.
The middle's fucked.
So I'm very hot on like,
if you look at the pop-up
museums in New York
it's like extreme candy, extreme colors.
It's like you've got
these you know mocktails
that are like $39, but they steam out.
Go extreme as fuck 'cause the picture.
It's the club dynamic.
Why do clubs right now have
when you order the champagne,
the sparklers come out.
People want attention.
They're not buying the champagne
they're buying the attention.
They want every dude and
girl in the club to look
and be like oh, that's the big baller.
In China it's got even more extreme
where they're doing like
interactive shit with QR codes
where the cool guy in the club
throws money on the screen
and then everybody can QR and take it.
Really.
So A, I love real life.
B, any way you can figure
out to be the most extremer
or the most subtle.
Don't live in middle.
The world is getting pulled that way,
because of the Internet,
The middle's bad.
It's really huge.
And then look at yourself
to figure out who you are.
The reason I think I work
is I'm a little bit of both.
I'm very outlandish in
my communication style,
but I'm very minimal in my like, right?
There is no jewelry.
Back to what you were saying.
That's not who I am.
And if I was that's cool,
I love authenticity.
Andy Frisella loves Lamborghinis for real
and so that's cool and he can afford them
and he's not renting them to look cool
to like make you pay for
a thousand dollar course.
So that's authentic.
Authenticity and left to right, no middle.
I love real life.
I think company should
activate in more real life
where I was going and I
brought it up a couple times,
B2B companies fucking buying
ads in B2B magazines for 20k
doing $130,000 fucking
build out an exhibit
and telling me they don't have $15,000
to run LinkedIn ads on content.
- [Woman] Gary, can we shift?
How are people shopping in 2021?
- I'm not sure, I'm really not,
but it's gonna be way
more Internet than not.
Last mile is gonna be here one day,
like just to create clarity
like everything you want
is gonna be delivered
within an hour in America,
but I mean for real.
And for there to like it's
really, like to his point,
in New York and other places sure,
but in nine years when
it's happening in his world
and he's picking up a bar of deodorant
'cause that's how we live.
Or the bar of deodorant
itself is reordering itself,
because Gillette's putting
you know technology in it
and it knows it's done and it's
just being delivered direct.
I don't know and 2021
is not that far away,
but what I can tell you is more Internet
less real-world.
- [Woman] What about apps?
- Who the fuck knows?
And I've been talking
more about it lately,
which is I don't know.
I know right now it's a good idea to
be using Instagram shop,
Shopify, Amazon, Facebook.
- [Woman] So continuing to leverage those?
- Just look at technology
think about what a Razor phone
that was the coolest
thing on earth in 2005,
if I put that in your in hand right now
what a piece of that would look like.
(laughing)
- [Man] I have a buddy, my aunt had a--
- Non smartphone?
- [Man] Non smartphone and it was crazy.
(laughing)
And I was like what are you doing?
- And what did she say?
- [Man] This is what I like.
- Mazel Tov.
- [Man] So besides Microsoft
and these other companies,
A.I., what companies do
you see that are down here
that are not discovered that
you're looking into investing?
- I'm not.
- [Man] You're not?
- Artificial intelligence
is like so far away
from when I give a fuck,
like I don't care about
anything that's not practical
in the short term.
Why?
Like there's too much
risk and like I mean,
it takes a long time for
technology to actually click.
- [Man] We're seeing it
fast though with the Alexa
and all that and that's
starting to happen.
- It is, it is, and I'm all about voice
and I'm super interested in that
and I've been obviously talking about it.
I think I don't get a
high on, I don't predict.
I don't know what else to say.
I don't predict.
Instagram story ads right now
are unbelievably under priced.
You should run as much as you can
for whatever the fuck you do.
- [Man] So in that real
world versus Internet,
the sales of that, would
you convert that better
with still having sales floor
being kind of the info space?
Would you still have the real person?
- I think both work, both work.
- [Man] And then I'll just follow up--
- It's similar to the...
here's the answer, they
both work similar to
trade shows and marketing,
but which one's better
and more opportunistic at
this moment is the debate.
Am I better off to have 37
guys and gals on the phone
closing this and having three
film people and running ads
and my allocation is 71%
of energy and resources
to the phone team versus 29 over here?
Or should it be 60/40, got it?
That's the game.
You understand?
It's that practical.
- [Woman] Everyone of us
regardless of the business
that we're in, even you with your father,
you were Youtube channel,
what you're doing with events,
value and I've heard you
talk about it so many times.
- It's about leverage,
life is about leverage.
So in a relationship the positive one
has the leverage over the
negative one in the long term,
but in the short term the negative one
has the leverage over the positive one.
Do you know how many cliche marriages end
when the one that was a
dick for 22 years is stunned
that out of nowhere the other one woke up
and said you know what, fuck you, I'm out.
And then they're like no,
no, no, what the fuck?
'Cause the leverage is
sat with the good one.
This is why I have all the leverage.
This is why when
everybody's confused by me
versus the other 45 faces that
pop up on pre-rolls and ads,
I'm going to win 'cause I'm
bringing the most value.
- [Man] Your content model.
- That's an absurd thing
to put out for free.
- [Man] Yeah, it really was.
- I'm aware, it was not
just what I normally do,
which is easy, we put time and effort
to like really give it to you.
Months, so it was tight and good
and like the most basic
person could go through it
80 pages five times like ah-ha.
- [Man] Who helps you
balance the practicality
of the financials of that?
- Me.
- [Man] Good answer.
- It's the truth.
- [Man] When you have
multiple streams income,
where do you pull...
so I've like six different income.
Where do you pull a salary when you have,
I mean, you have way more right?
Like your on down here, I
know where I'm currently,
I'm thinking is that the right...
'cause I'm revenue coming in from about
six different businesses
that I either have equity ownership in,
what is your guidance on that?
- So I always invest in
things that I think have,
like I look at the year
ahead, not too much.
I don't get too crazy far out.
Like if a business is growing I feed it.
And so for me one of the
reasons I write books or speak
is it allows me to make income
so I can continue to
invest in my businesses.
And I try to keep my overhead low,
which has been harder
over the last couple years
just growing family, just like, you know,
as time evolves you're like after you eat,
you know you heard my story
14 to 34, it's like...
When I started giving to
charity along the way,
you might have heard
the charity water story
I've mentioned a lot of
times where Scott's like
don't do what you think you're gonna do
and give it all away at 85.
Do it along the way.
I'm like oh yeah that kind
of affected my real life too,
which is like you know what?
As much as I do play for the long-term,
it's not terrible to enjoy a little some.
- [Man] They've given us
exclusive access to turn
those people and a custom
audiences on Facebook.
The leverage off of those
people to market to people
that have other events.
What I don't want to give
up is the digital marketing
side of it, but I don't want
to continue to go too far,
like four different
directions with the business
at the same time, does that make sense?
- Of course it does.
The leverage is the having
the practitioner ship ability
in the execution of
under priced attention.
Your question is answered in
what I'm doing for a living.
- [Man] True.
- Very true.
What the fuck am I doing?
I believe in its so much
that after having unlimited
leverage financially,
reputationally, I'm still doing it.
That's my answer.
- [Man] It's good.
- It is good and more
importantly as you know
when Facebook changes, A, as
somebody who's a real player
I'm telling you I'm going back in.
Then there's gonna be, to her question,
in 2021 a new app called water,
which is gonna be the
number one app in the world
and it's Instagram meets fucking AR
meets I don't fucking know.
But the game of all you did was
just tell a modern-day story
of what I did on Google for Wine Library,
it's what you talked about earlier.
The skill of marketing and
sales and getting attention
when it's a good deal
at an under priced level
can let you be a fucking wood sign maker,
can help you sell fucking jewelry.
It is the ultimate thing.
Attention of human beings is the asset.
What you deploy that attention
to can be low margin,
but you're passion about
it can be high margin,
can be whatever the you want,
but there's the oxygen of a business.
Exploding.
It's the oxygen of a business exploding.
You can do cold calling.
That could be the oxygen.
I'm talking about why do
companies have hyper growth?
Because you bought
beachfront property in Malibu
before anybody understood
it was beachfront property in Malibu.
Attention.
- [Man] Well attention is great,
but I think psychology too.
Knowing how they actually--
- Which just gets me to the next part,
which is why I was so quick
to not be pumped about data.
I can get in front of
everybody with information.
Now tell me what you're
putting in front of them.
I can low your CAC based on creative.
- [Man] Yeah well that's what
changed our whole business--
- Of course it did, of course.
- [Man] We went from one pricing model
and changed the entire thing
and we've now got quadruple the numbers.
- How about the fact that there's a video
you haven't made yet that
will lower the numbers
or double the numbers even more.
It's the volume of content.
- [Man] Voice, you
talked a lot about voice.
- I do because it's
gonna take over search.
- [Man] So how do you do voice and how do,
I mean I don't want to say
just apply to our business,
but how do you--
- I don't know yet.
Because I think Amazon and Google
have disproportionate leverage.
Hey Alexa, I want to go
to a race this weekend,
where should I go?
You know how expensive the next sentence
from the machine is gonna be?
A, Amazon's gonna be like fuck you,
I'm not gonna let you pay
ten thousand dollars a lead.
I'm just gonna create a fucking company,
put you out of business.
- [Man] How you get ahead of it?
- You don't.
you better hope that they
don't want that model.
you just hope it's not your turn.
The Internet's gonna kill everybody.
It just they killed taxi drivers first.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)